[Music]
Miley Cyrus has a new song and yeah
we're pretty sure it's about Liam
Hemsworth the 26 year old dropped slide
away on Friday it's her first music
release since announcing her split from
her hubby just about a week ago take a
listen
[Music]
the emotional single appears to tell a
story of a painful breakup and a
relationship falling apart after trying
to make things work
[Music]
the album art features a bottle of
whiskey several orange pill bottles and
pills floating in a pool those images
are also in the song along with
references to Miley having moved from
the city to Malibu to be with Liam
whiskey
[Music]
after Miley and Liam split reports
surfaced that Liam's alleged
hard-partying lifestyle drove him and
Miley apart though a source denied that
allegation to ET still it's hard to
ignore all the other links to Liam in
the song like this one
[Music]
[Music]
Miley and Liam met when she was just 17
on the set of the last song so yeah this
song has me deep in my feelings I just
need a minute okay I'm back now let's
get into the latest with a couple
formerly known as my am a source
recently told et that while Miley was
the one who asked for the break they
quote both knew the split was coming she
still feels the need to explore herself
her sexuality and her music Miley has
been working in the studio and wants to
blow off steam and while Miley is
blowing off steam in the studio her
post-breakup makeout partner Caitlin
Carter is breaking her silence after
their hot and heavy trip to Italy
together the 30 year old blogger
recorded a live podcast on Thursday
night with her Hill's new beginnings
co-star Whitney Port and while she
didn't open up about her romantic
getaway with the singer she did get
candid about her hesitancy to sign on to
the series with her now x hn ur whom she
split from earlier this month after five
years together it seemed like kind of a
crazy idea to be her Brody to be back on
TV and for me to be on there in the
first place cuz I'm a
really like my comfort zone right but
then I also thought it would be fun the
decision really was about whether for us
to be able to spend more time together
this story is so juicy and legit doesn't
seem to have an end in sight of course
you can count on us to keep you up to
date on all the latest so make sure to
keep it locked right here on ET until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]